inventor author independent scientist
James Lovelock works out of a barn
turned laboratory in the English
countryside he's best known as the
father of Gaia theory the idea that all
parts of our planet living and
non-living form a complex interacting
system like a single organism his latest
book depicts Gaia in peril the earth as
we know it is vanishing and this is
James Lovelock's final warning Jim
thanks very much for joining us
so what bullying you because you'll have
your large 8th birthday and many happy
returns and also things but I'm a
spaceman how did you come to be in my
two year old spaceman oh well it was it
was rather funny really a friend of mine
in America sent me a an urgent message
saying hey do you know Richard Branson
is going to be advertising biofuels
under the title Gaia Gaia biofuels for
Virgin Airlines and that's what can't do
that and so I sent in an email saying
look you can't do this it's almost as
bad as me opening a chain of brothels
and calling it Virgin I got back with
nice lease reply from Richard Branson he
obviously found it very funny and so not
the slightest intention of sort of
screwing up the Geyer name because he'd
been a fan for donkey's years and then
added what would you think about having
a trip into space
next year or sometime would you ever in
your youth of thought I might be an
astronaut one day no no not in my
wildest dreams
I mean so what a wonderful thing to
happen when you're 92 no no terrific but
some some people will say that this is
somewhat environmentally reckless thing
to do to burn lots of fuels elect some
people 100 kilometres up above the earth
well anybody who says that I think well
even great gravely misguided
or else a damned hypocrite
because if you what yeah that if you
gave them the jobs there and they were
of that inclination they've taken but on
a sad note I mean your your current book
is extremely pessimistic I think about
about where the planet is going because
of the carbon prices the climate crisis
what you call global heating which is a
much tougher term than global warming do
you think that in in 90 years time at
the end of the 21st century do you think
they'll still be people going into space
I think it's very how likely do you
think we're going to lose that sort of
technological capability I think would
be far too busy surviving to have the
time or the money or the energy to do it
and it won't be considered that's
important so do you think you may be one
of the last basement it's a possibility
but I don't think the tough times are
coming next year or in the next 10 years
even I think the little further down the
track but when it comes I suspect it'll
be very rapid indeed one things I found
interesting about the modelling work you
talk about in the book is that it's the
opposite of looking darkest just before
the dawn
it might look brightest just before the
forward light because you say that it
may look reserved the biological systems
are doing most just before they
effectively come out absolutely the
reasons this is quite simple as soon as
the system grows unstable it goes into
positive feedback and the as the
positive feedback strengthens then any
small perturbation in either direction
gets amplified so tendency to cooling
will give you a real cold winter and it
says towards heating the real hot summer
they'll finally could flip so right the
way up to it's hot spit so when some
people look at the look at the cold
weather this winter and say oh maybe not
so much then you look at it and say more
extremes because the system
becoming stressed and more sensitive yes
so you were saying about the fact that
scientists work in an institutional
setting in a political setting you of
course famously don't you became an
independent of those I know but you
became an independent scientist what
about half your life ago yes it would be
in 1964 and that's clearly worked out
very well for you do you think people
like what Richard Branson or Bill Gates
or the boys of Google would you say what
you should do is just set some money on
some people so they can go out and be
independent scientists know that's the
last thing to do give them a big pot of
money or just go have a good time or
worse it's a good time well I know that
it wasn't just by spending money I I
spent my last three years as the thought
professor at Baylor College of Medicine
with an enormous son which is in Texas
yes heads yes yes but the the awful
thing was that I had an almost unlimited
pot of money to spend on equipment and
there was a three most unproductive
years of my life we've just bought
larger and larger more exciting pieces
of gear and then spend all our time
playing with it only dawned on me
towards the end of that period there's
of course they were about five years out
of date
you heat the inventions on which they
were based take that time to reach the
even the forefront of the manufacturing
sale so if you just got invented
something simple you're naturally miles
ahead of the game and this is one of the
impetus that drove me
defenders do you still tinker with
things in your workshop oh you bear
interesting what you wanted what about
20,000 trees about I got any planted
that's those about 4,000 or sir that's
quite enough it gives me all sorts of
carbon trading bonus points in July a
[ __ ] about that pays for my tripping
district times more than over you now
think you should just let that land grow
back into scrub and would absolutely you
see this is the trouble with not only
the climate science but also Green
philosophy and green action they
theorize all the time and never do
experiments now people seem to have
forgotten that experiment and
observation are at least half of science
C and if being neglected and this is an
example if they say isn't it good to
plant trees have they tried it well when
you do try you soon find out it isn't a
good idea at all and the reason it isn't
is that you can't plant an ecosystem
ecosystem contains everything from
bacteria up through a maybe nematodes
insects invertebrates all the way up to
giant trees and you can't plant that no
way it has to come naturally and much
more important than that as the climate
changes as it is now the ecosystem
adapts beautifully the plantation stem
soon as the climate comes unfavorable
they die you're talking book as I said
it is in some ways I think pessimistic
open which is not necessarily to say an
unrealistic book about a vastly
decreased human population but you also
say that one thing that we should be
considering as a possible counterweight
about geoengineering about ways of
taking the edge of the temperature creat
increases the heating that that we see
going on around us since we can have a
slightly ambivalent attitude to
geoengineering well Oliver we're all a
bit ambivalent it's in our natures and
I'm an inventor
that's very much my life so naturally
I'm interested in geoengineering and I
think they're all things worth trying
because they'll produce results in the
way of observations and it'll tell us
more about the earth so it's worth it
from that point of view but the other
thing is I think is there is an outside
chance that one procedure could really
turn back the clock on global warming
and that is burying carbon all you have
to do is to get every farmer everywhere
to make a profit by turning all of his
egg waste into char and burying it or
dropping it in the sea doesn't matter
which because but char is not only
resistant to atmospheric oxidation it's
non biodegradable too so it'll just stay
there but overall you might want to find
slightly puzzling about your book given
how engaged with the world you are
there's a certain sanguine approach to
thinking of in your ideas billions of
people are dying and I is it because
it's just too vast a thought to to
extend compassion I'd like to push you a
little bit on that well please do know
it's a thing that's concerned me deeply
obviously it has to but then on the
other hand I think it's part of human
nature at least it used to be when I was
young if you heard there been a famine
in China and a million people had died
you cared about that less and if your
dog had died and it's just we don't get
all that steamed up about some people
who are not familiar to us but it
happens and his happen and don't forget
that in the Earth's history while humans
have been on on the planet that's about
a million years there have been seven
major climate events of this kind and I
think the geneticists say that at one of
those events we were reduced to a mere
2,000 individuals the bottleneck genetic
bottleneck if that's true then they are
very violent
indeed and the one up ahead looks every
bit as violent if not more so than the
ones that have happened in the past
so I may be under estimating their
deaths toll not overestimate despite
this accepting this terrible death talk
a terrible die back also in an odd way I
feel more positive about humans and
their relationship to guide the new have
been sometimes in the past time you
think humans really do add something to
the planet not yet early on in the
evolution of life on Earth as is so
beautifully described in your book
Oliver eating the Sun photosynthesizers
appeared with this remarkable capacity
to split water using sunlight and a
quite complicated series of biochemical
reactions and they flourished but their
waste product oxygen was in those times
not a very nice guess to put out if you
in many ways about as nasty as something
producing chlorine know that we all got
used to it I think that we are like
humans just like those photosynthesizes
at the beginning we've discovered
intelligence if you like or acquired it
but we have it and it's a very powerful
capacity communicating intelligence and
it's enabled us through in industrial
development in the inventions to do all
sorts of earth-shaking things and many
of them are damaging just as oxygen was
but I think that the system will adapt
and there is a possibility that humans
have a huge future because they are as
desirable to the planet in many ways as
the photosynthesizes were so they're our
descendants way down the tracks could be
the kind of animals that make the whole
planet intelligent and possibly extend
its lifespan significantly do you have
any hope that we gradually short short
circuit the system and get wise and
thoughtful without
I've thought about this a great deal
Oliver and it might be possible if by
some exceedingly illegal and amoral kind
of setup you selected the the best or
what you thought the best of humans the
moment and form them into a small
society somewhere that you might be able
to dream up ways of doing these things
and doing it now but we can't do that
for all sorts of reasons and we are what
we are we're the the average and
intelligence varies as much as hype does
but with what little intelligence we
have now we can look back on the planet
and we can send people who look back on
the planet up in spacecraft after their
90th birthday
it's Ansel exactly well it's something
Fitz Jim thank you very much for joining
us well thank you honor for some very
nice questions
you